meditation because mathematicians are
notoriously boring and dumb creative we
cool with setup functions the same name
we call them function okay and then
after this in the brackets what would
you expect to see there usually usually
that's right now all that means is what
you've got up here is the name of the
function and over here the input now
because we're saying this is a function
and not a relation right and you would
say this is equal to Y that's wrap and
there should just be one of them okay
but just before we run off from this
this name and input idea that's not F
doesn't have to be X you can do anything
you like so for instance I could say a
let's see now what does this mean look
at it you recognize it
what's going on um hey is what I'm
naming this function okay what's it
short for area and more specifically
area of right now the ervice circle is a
function you put in an input is only
give me one output right so your input
is your radius right that's your
important okay and there's your output
there's your what the actual area is
okay so because this is a function if
you've got two circles and they put in
that radius 5 they're gonna have the one
area cuz it's just one out makes sense
okay so just carrying on from here right
how this function notation but all you
really have to get is that if you stick
a number in here like that
it's in radius five how do you actually
evaluate this what do you do
it's just substitution right that's all
that it's so everywhere you used to see
our final now just before I leave off it
I extend it this way and sitting in
functions can be named anything you like
and these inputs can be anything you
like you can also have functions which
have a multiple influence right so you
could say I just connected a no that's
good
let's do you tell me
by yourself thank you but of course the
volume of cylinder doesn't depend on
just one input you need two things
how tall it is - okay so sometimes
you'll see this they get thrown off
you're like how do I do
there's lots of things in there yes -
this okay all that means is those your
inputs still whatever